backstage i was talking to you very
briefly and you're sort of talking about
how you you kind of live
you don't live in the city city part of
los angeles you live out
in the in the country a little bit right
a little bit i live in this really
magical land called topanga canyon
wow it's the magical world of topaz it
is there's no
cell phone reception there's very little
internet it's awesome there's a small
little public library still
that people go to and you don't have a
television and you
pride yourself a little bit on on on
kind of enjoying the land
living a natural life would you say yeah
i love it i love it i definitely live
a different lifestyle i would say than
a lot of people i know right or have met
but but you're not like uh would you say
survivalist you were survivalists could
you live off the land if you had to
i think i could maybe for a few days
survive i mean it's one of those things
that of course you think you can and
then you're in that situation you're
like oh my god how do i make fire again
i forgot this isn't working
are you comfortable like can you find
berries or anything in the woods that
you would eat
i'm just curious like i'm never
comfortable doing that i unless
you're afraid it would be boise unless i
saw a hamburger growing on a branch
i i wouldn't but yeah but i'd be afraid
of eating the wrong thing are you pretty
comfortable saying oh that looks good
chomp yeah for the most part i am except
for with mushrooms those guys are a
little scary
because they can kill you yeah it can
either be an amazing experience
it could either be or your last
experience
you tweeted recently i'm so obsessed
with toads
yeah i am let's talk about that i
do you like toads sure why not i think
they're great
and what does that what do you like
about toe i mean first of all you saw a
toad and
okay i was in the middle of the desert
in arizona we were at some beautiful hot
springs
and this toad jumped up and according to
like native american
tradition this tone meant toad meant
like good luck and was supposed to bring
you messages and whatnot but
it was just beautiful and the fact that
it could survive in the middle of
nowhere in this one small little
oasis of water it just it fascinated me
i thought it was a really neat
little animal a little cool little
amphibian you know what i like i like
getting obsessed or not excited about
something that's more commonplace you
know what i mean it's like it's nice
it's nice to say like
look at something in nature and get
excited about it a toad
yeah it was huge too it was i have giant
hands i have giant hands for a woman
and the toad is bigger than my hands wow
do you walk around measuring things
against your
sometimes because they're so big i feel
like it's a good way to sort of measure
things
uh did um okay so uh the toad obviously
that was a great
uh you seem very upbeat and positive is
that true is that's the
that's the i'm gonna say vibe but that's
what that's what i'm getting is that
you're a very upbeat person i am i love
life
i'm a life lover that's good do you wake
up do you wake up every day and because
i'm uh i wake up every day and go like i
hate it all
i'm like the grinch and like i'll get
those who poohville people
i wake up every day and i sing a song or
like a little phrase of a song
you know that song good morning good
morning yeah
every morning and then sometimes i'll
follow it up and i'll say like exciting
day
exciting day oh wow that would not go
over in my house
if they're friends over i don't do it
because i know it's a little bit intense
for them but when you're working when
you're making it like 5 30 a.m every day
and you have to sort of be in front of a
lot of people right i feel like
i have to wake myself up first that's
good and i'm not a morning person